Trump
[Music]
this is Brian in tahar senior creative
director at Insomniac games thank you
for all of your amazing feedback to our
demo at the Showcase earlier this year
Marvel Spider-Man 2 is filled with an
amazing story and story missions but
today I'm here to provide you with a
first look at how the open World
experience is evolving and how the game
is built to take full advantage of the
PlayStation 5.
the first thing you'll notice is that
our city has nearly doubled in size with
addition of two iconic Newark boroughs
queens and Brooklyn
and we've introduced the web Wings an
entirely new mechanic that we combine
with web swinging allows you to Traverse
the city in a whole new way and have
faster speeds than ever before whether
it's a neighborhood backdrop of queens
or the fireworks that light up the sky
over Coney Island exploring these areas
will feel much different than the
Towering skyscrapers of Manhattan while
also delivering memorable cows like
Peter Parker's old stomping grounds in
Midtown high and Miles Morales current
place of learning broken Visions Academy
hey miles what's up speaking of our
heroes Marvel Spider-Man 2 will
introduce the ability to switch between
the two wall crawlers in the open world
and thanks to the power of the
PlayStation 5 you can make that switch
almost instantly
delivering a bigger city and playing as
not one but two spider Heroes were big
goals for Marvel Spider-Man 2. but this
time around it was equally important to
provide a greater sense of exploration
and Discovery as you progress through
the main story a number of new
activities and storylines will become
available the majority of those will now
be represented by visual cues in the
world that grab your attention such as a
flock of Craven's Talon drones circling
a building a mysterious symbol projected
into the sky AI or even an unfamiliar
spiderbot ping emitting from one of the
rooftops many activities like the
Hunter's cloaked blinds Overlook the Big
Apple lead to even greater challenges
yet yield worthy rewards and new
information about Marvel's greatest
hunter Craven others will lead to a
climactic showdown on Marvel villains
not yet seen in the Spider-Man universe
the spider Heroes have new AR Tech in
the lens of their masks providing a
quick glimpse of activities already
discovered or helping locate new ones
yet to be revealed you can always refer
to the upgraded friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man app to quickly track nearby
areas of Interest the app will also
include incoming requests from those who
call Marvel's New York home
some will ask for either spider hero to
help While others like the students of
Brooklyn Visions calling upon miles will
require you to put on the mask of a
specific hero all these activities
including crime to stop from The Game's
various enemy factions awesome now feed
into the new District progress system
which even provides more rewards and
unlocks our brand new fast travel system
as you can see here the PlayStation 5
and its SSD means you can move across
the city with very little downtime
finally the more City you explore and
the more activities you complete the
more ways you'll be able to customize
your spider hero this includes mastering
additional combat abilities and
traversal skills acquiring improving
gadgets upgrading through the new suit
Tech system and of course unlocking
additional spider suits and we're
talking lots and lots of Suits Marvel
Spider-Man 2 will feature over 65 suits
from the comics movies and multiple
original designs and thanks to the
all-new seat style system you'll now
have more than 200 different ways to
outfit your friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man
on behalf of Insomniac games we couldn't
be more excited about what this Hispanic
city has to offer and all the new ways
you'll experience Marvel's New York we
look forward to seeing you swinging
around in Marvel Spider-Man 2 when it
launches October 20th only on
PlayStation 5.
[Music]